[Music]
on this Thursday night personal
protective equipment on the way for
Canada's frontline workers the Prime
Minister's promise last night we
received a shipment why doctors and
nurses say they need it and more right
now mounting pressure to reveal the
disease models governments are using to
plan you deserve to know plus a tale of
two neighbors why Canada and the US are
on different trajectories in this
pandemic a warning about dating apps
Meuse white right you might get more
than you bargained for
what are mild symptoms more answers to
your coronavirus questions
global national with Donna freezing
good evening and thanks for joining us
lots of developments to get to on this
Thursday we all longed to lead with a
story that's not related to this virus
but today is not that day today the
world reached a new milestone more than
1 million people around the world are
now confirmed to have kovat 19 and the
number of confirmed cases in Canada is
still rising steadily more than 11,000
people in this country are known to have
the virus and more than 160 people have
died nearly half of them were in
long-term care and retirement homes
Quebec reported the biggest spike today
907 new cases there the number of
infections is also rising everywhere
those numbers do not include all the
people who have not been tested yet or
who are still waiting for test results
many countries including the US and the
UK have released infectious disease
models they are using to plan for the
impact of this virus the models give
projections of different scenarios best
case and worst case Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau says he knows Canadians
want to see those numbers and
predictions and that he said today will
happen soon Ontario's premier went a
step further today Doug Ford says he'll
release Ontario's models tomorrow and he
says they'll be a wake-up call the
situation is extremely extremely serious
you deserve to see the same data that I
see when I'm making decisions you
deserve to know what I know when you're
making decisions for yourself your
family and your community
we don't need projections to know what's
already happens in other countries
Canadian hospitals are preparing for a
surge like we've seen in Italy Spain and
the United States health care workers we
know have been raising the alarm about
shortages of personal protective
equipment masks gloves and gowns
tonight the Canadian Medical Association
has a stark new picture of how badly
that is all needed the CMA surveyed
5,000 doctors this week more than a
third in offices and walk-in clinics say
they'll run out of now n95 masks the
face shields and goggles within two days
or less in some cases they've already
run out physicians in hospital settings
aren't sure how long there
supplies will last many say they're
already being asked to ration supplies
federal officials say more supplies are
on the way and production in Canada is
being ramped up the Health Minister did
admit the disease models even the best
case scenarios show that our health care
system will be overwhelmed
ultimately at the end of the day our
health system cannot cope with the surge
it was never designed to see that many
critical patients all at once nor would
any system around the world be designed
as we have seen from countries all
around the world try to get ready for
this surgery
Mercedes Stevenson is with me from
Ottawa Mercedes getting personal
protective equipment is a matter of life
and death for doctors and nurses what's
the latest on what is coming and when it
will arrive
well Donna help is on the way but the
question is whether it will make it to
the front lines fast enough these are
the most recent stats that we have from
the Government of Canada I got them just
before we went to air so far
ten million masks have arrived this week
another 1.1 million
arrived overnight those are all surgical
masks though not the n95 kinds with the
ventilator on them now staff are going
through these masks I'm told 24 hours a
day to vet them and get them out 174
ventilators have now gone out to the
provinces and there's more coming in but
to give you a sense of the overall
numbers Donna there's a hundred and
fifty seven million surgical masks yet
to come sixty point nine million of
those n95 s that haven't shown up yet
and about four thousand ventilators how
doctors and nurses on the frontlines are
saying they need this desperately now
take a listen to what the Canadian
Medical Association had to say we really
feel that we're at a crisis point and
it's causing physicians nurses and other
health care workers on the front line
immense anxiety and additional stress
that they don't need right now now Donna
the federal government says that the
provinces all have orders in as well but
on this call tonight with the premiers
this is one of the things they're going
to be discussing is who is in the most
urgent need and starting to move those
supplies as quickly as possible ok
Mercedes let's talk about the disease
models Ontario's premier says he's going
to release that provinces disease models
tomorrow he says people deserve to see
the same projections they
he is seeing the Prime Minister said
last week the federal public health
models would be released too but they
haven't been do we know why not well
Donna so far the Prime Minister says
that they have concerns about accuracy
and they're trying to make sure that the
models reflect reality take a listen to
what he said to reporters earlier today
you know we're coordinating with the
provinces to make sure that the data is
consistent right across the country and
that is the number is that we are
putting through into various models and
as we get those models more accurate we
look forward to sharing them with
Canadians the federal government is
under increasing pressure to release
their modeling part of that means they
have to get the modeling from the
provinces all of whom have been doing
this differently but experts say
releasing these models could help with
behavior Donna if people see how bad
things could get all right Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thanks there's some
relief tonight for hundreds of Canadians
stranded on board to cruise ships off
the coast of Florida the ships have been
granted permission to dock at Port
Everglades Global News has confirmed
nearly 250 passengers are scheduled to
fly to Toronto tomorrow morning the
cruise ships one of which has confirmed
cases of kovat 19 on board have been
desperate to find a port for weeks Mike
Gourley explains what happens next the
early morning Florida Hayes turned into
midday clarity for 250 Canadians living
in isolation on a pair of Holland
America cruise ships including Michelle
piron's
75 year old mother Jocelyn she's elated
there's a plan she's got a piece of
paper with a plan and this is the first
time in in over a week that they've had
any kind of direction in terms of what
was happening after 27 days at sea
they've finally been given the green
light to come home my understanding is
they will be a flown home on a charter
flight the Canadians are among 2,500
passengers and crew that were supposed
to disembark in Chile on March 21st but
after four people died and another 233
showed flu-like symptoms aboard the
zaandam Chile closed its ports and the
passengers were forced to isolate
do you want to definition like cabin
fever this is yes two-thirds of the
passengers were transferred to a second
ship the Rotterdam and both tried to
dock in Florida only to be turned away
we have enough to deal with with our
folks in Florida the reaction was
overwhelming come from a way trended on
Twitter reminding Florida's governor how
Canadians welcomes stranded Americans
after 9/11 the sequel to come from a way
is gonna really suck red one and facing
political pressure from the left we
Americans don't turn people away and the
right Florida's governor relented
although only Florida residents can stay
and that's perfectly fine for Canadians
like Chris Joyner
they'll have to isolate when they return
but at least they're no longer lost at
sea Micro Lake Global News Toronto the
US now has more than 240,000 confirmed
cases of Cove in 19 and more than 5,700
people have died the economic toll is
becoming more and more clear in the last
week six point six million people filed
unemployment claims in the span of two
weeks ten million jobs have disappeared
Jackson prosecco has a status report on
where America is at right now in cities
across the u.s. they're preparing for
what's to come new field hospitals are
under construction and convention
centers and stadiums in every corner of
the country everyone fears they'll be
the next New York where hundreds of new
deaths were reported overnight it's so
bad paramedics have been told not to
transport unresponsive patients to the
hospital if they can't be revived in the
field medical supplies are now
critically low we have about six days of
ventilators in our stockpile hospitals
everywhere face the same shortages the
US national stockpile is critically low
two states say the thousands of
ventilators on order will arrive too
late there's little sympathy from
Washington where President Trump tweeted
a message to
governors and hospitals we are a backup
for them the complainer should have been
stocked up and ready long before this
crisis hit what do you see is the
greatest failure of the US response we
spoke with Jeremy canine dike an expert
in pandemic preparedness I think the
greatest failure and and it's really the
the failure that everything else derives
from was the failure to take this
seriously in like January today the u.s.
is bracing for a predicted 100,000 to
240,000 coronavirus deaths that
best-case scenario may not be achievable
some states are only now implementing
stay at home orders having waited until
their case numbers and fatalities
started to climb if anything it's
possible that we may see more cases than
those models projected obviously I hope
we don't but what's clear is there are a
lot of parts of this country that are on
a similar trajectory to New York in a
sign of how rapidly things are now
changing in the US public health
officials are broadly recommending that
Americans cover their faces when they're
out in public they say a scarf or a
homemade mask is all that it could take
to slow the spread of coronavirus at
this point they do not want people
wearing surgical or medical grade masks
because they're in such short supply
Donna Jackson Prosecco in Washington
thanks in this country nearly 60,000 of
Canada's 68,000 troops are now in
self-isolation not because they're sick
but to keep them ready general Jonathan
Vance tells global news they'll be able
to deploy across Canada if necessary to
help with a pandemic we are watching
that outbreak at Pine Crest nursing home
in Ontario two more residents have now
died 16 people in the home have now
passed away from kovat 19 plus the wife
of one resident more than two dozen
staff members are also infected the
outbreak was made public in mid-march at
the 65 bed facility and a local health
unit says it is the largest outbreak in
Ontario but we're all being forced to
find ways to cope during this pandemic
and it's taking a toll on our mental
health today Ontario's premier announced
he's investing 12 million dollars into
virtual mental health supports programs
such as Kids Help Phone and
it's back you're not alone we're
listening we care if you're struggling
please reach out talk to someone if you
know someone who may be struggling talk
to them pick up the phone
the Health Minister in Newfoundland and
Labrador is occurr encouraging people to
plan virtual gatherings over Easter
he's also warning people about dating
apps which he says have seen increased
use during this pandemic let me warn you
if you use tinder or Grindr and you
swipe right you might get more than you
bargained for so please be careful
Newfoundland and Labrador is bracing for
a surge in cases there are 183 there now
most of the link to funerals that took
place at one st. John's funeral home
Canada's pandemic plan for prisons
coming up the potential solutions to
stop outbreaks behind bars
anyone who is confined in close quarters
with other people is at high risk and
that includes prisoners and corrections
officers there are already confirmed
cases in facilities in Canada and as
Ross Lord explains advocacy groups say
unless Canada's most vulnerable inmates
are removed from institutions the
consequences could be deadly at this
time of shifting lifestyles another
surprising move could be in the works
releasing prison inmates during the
pandemic we think there's really only
one way to prevent the spread of the
virus and that is to release as many
prisoners as possible into safe and
supportive housing in the community
advocates say it should start with
offenders who are elderly nonviolent or
with medical conditions that leave them
especially vulnerable they say otherwise
kovat 19 could kill large clusters of
inmates a former inmate of this women's
prison in nova scotia says fending off
contagion is impossible the common areas
are too small to be practicing physical
or social distancing they share
bathrooms they share the kitchens they
share the common areas some inmates have
been granted a temporary absence mostly
those who are serving sentences and
weekends at provincial jails like this
one but the federal government has
resisted calls to release nonviolent
prisoners from federal institutions
Ottawa says Public Safety Minister Bill
Blair is checking to determine whether
there are measures that could be taken
to facilitate early release for certain
offenders Correctional Service Canada
says it's preventing the spread of kovat
19 through measures like suspending
visits to inmates but in several
institutions infection is taking hold
including pork cart Jake Quebec where
some inmates and staff have tested
positive and the Grand Valley
institution for women in Ontario which
is reporting an infected inmate some
provincial jails including the Saskatoon
Correctional Center have several
infected staff members should it happen
the likelihood of it spreading wildly
across the population is very hot the
correctional officers union says the
answer is changing routines within
institutions not releasing inmates no
easy answer for another pandemic
raus lower global news Dartmouth Nova
Scotia
still ahead comparing the pandemic paths
of Canada and the United States
many in the u.s. now realize political
leaders there have not acted fast enough
new cases have quickly outpaced some of
the world's hardest hit countries
including South Korea which reported its
first case on the same day as the United
States America has been slow to test and
slow to order people to stay home
political leaders are fighting over
precious medical supplies now that's a
sharp contrast to the Team Canada
approach here it's not perfect here
either we have shortages too and people
are dying here too but as Eric Sorenson
explains we're in a better position than
our neighbors to the Sabbath closing the
border may prove to be a blessing for
this country the virus for weeks the US
president downplayed the risks April you
know in theory when it gets a little
warmer miraculously goes away hope
that's true even when Donald Trump
acknowledged the seriousness of kovat 19
many state governments held off stay at
home policies New York Times analysis of
cell phone data tracked Americans travel
last week in New York State virtually
none in many states still lots of travel
from devastated New York came this
warning look at us today see yourself
tomorrow in Florida where so many
Canadians spent time in March beaches
for a while still teamed with people
they eventually closed though the
governor only issued a statewide stay
home order on April the first see people
thought Easter all that that's not gonna
happen
in Canada the crisis struck and
governments of different stripes
mobilized together stay at home stay in
your homes all levels of government
including mayor's got on the same page
every single one of us stay home and the
streets here largely emptied Canada and
the US were on different paths through
the middle of March the number of cases
in the United States was outpacing the
number of cases in Canada at about ten
to one that makes sense in terms of
population but by the end of the month
Canada had moved up into the low
thousands the United States had
skyrocketed from there the u.s. now
outpacing the number of cases in Canada
by 22 to 1 a full-blown crisis is now
underway south of the border I hope we
can do this by Easter it didn't help
Americans weighing the seriousness
to see the White House forecasting an
early end that its own experts would not
predict obviously no one is gonna want
to tone down things when you see what's
going on in a place like New York City
have dr. string answer that in Canada
political leaders have consistently
deferred to specialists wealth if dr.
Tam has an additional comment the
medical experts have become the voice of
Canada's pandemic policy medical masks
respirators must be preserved for health
workers Canadians are not out of the
woods but we can also feel for our
American neighbors and the sheer scale
of the catastrophe they now confront
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto next
survivors offer firsthand advice for
your Co bid 19 concerns
for more than a month Global News has
been working to find answers to your
questions about kovat 19 and one that
keeps coming up is what it's like to
actually have the virus
our Jeff sample has been speaking
directly to Canadian patients to find
out Jeff well Donna for the past few
weeks we've been taking viewer questions
straight to the experts but this time
round we're asking a group with
first-hand knowledge of what Co vid 19
can do I'm feeling like a bird that's
been out of the nest
Karen shoemaker has never felt so
excited to be in her kitchen
there's my steel-cut oatmeal that I'm
cooking for myself for breakfast for the
first time in a long time she's just
completed three weeks of quarantine one
of the first people in BC to be
diagnosed I was in that right age group
to be really dangerous
one viewer named Wayne wrote in to ask
do the symptoms of covin 19 include a
loss of taste or smell shoemaker says
that was actually one of her first
symptoms I couldn't taste coffee so I
would say don't bother making a pot
light I can't taste it Deb wrote in to
say I understand most people are only
experiencing mild symptoms can you
please elaborate on what mild means Kyla
Leigh's kovat 19 is considered mild but
it sure doesn't feel that way
be plagued with a fever for two weeks a
call for over two weeks
shortness of breath even the most basic
activities that's not fun and for that
to go on for a long period of time when
you're completely alone is scary
Kirsten wrote in to ask should younger
people with underlying health conditions
such as asthma be self isolating and not
going into work
Emilio Merritt thinks so he suffers from
asthma and kovat 19 landed him in
hospital the way that you can operate is
totally different because the eyes know
when I get the asthma he's more like a
wheezing like
that's more like when the asthma thing
and this one is more like you cannot get
air inside and Terry wrote in to ask
could you please provide a real
description of the devastating symptoms
individuals are suffering Aaron Lee is
just 38 she's been in hospital for a
week really that's the big thing is just
not being able to catch my breath
Lee has an underlying medical condition
but no recent travel history so as far
as we know it's community transmission
Lee and all of the patients we spoke
with also have a message for the viewers
they say please keep your distance and
if you can stay home Donna can't say
that often enough Jeff simple in Toronto
thanks that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna freezin we leave you
tonight with some lockdown masterpieces
this modern Mona Lisa is part of a new
art collection inspired by a call from
the Getty Museum art lovers around the
world we're asked to recreate famous
works using only what they have at home
some pretty creative ones thanks for
watching take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]